I grew up in the fringes of the oil
business in Tulsa,
Tulsa called itself the oil capital of
the world in the 19 fifties and it
wasn't real far off.
It was very central to a lot of oil
companies,
oil equipment,
and the rest and most people in
business,
a very large share of them were in the
oil business in one way or another.
Well,
so anybody who's familiar with the oil
business knows that up until the early
20th century you could only get gasoline
from a tiny share of petroleum,
but first with thermal cracking and then
in the thirties catalytic cracking,
you could use much larger share,
70,
80 percent maybe of oil to produce
gasoline.
And it was that expansion of the
feedstock that made possible the
Transportation Revolution of the early
20th century.
As a reason,
gasoline was twenty five cents a gallon
when I was growing up in Tulsa.
Detroit doesn't produce the oil
and the United States produces some oil
certainly,
and we're going to need oil for a long
time,
but if we can get to a lot less oil than
we have now,
we can do something very important.
I'll give you one example.
Any corn of the Igs,
a think tank in in Washington that
promotes
working on energy for national security
purposes says that um,
up until the late 19th,
early 20th century salt was a strategic
commodity.
There was no other way to preserve meat.
Preserving meat was hugely important for
the human diet,
huge share of the human food chain.
So people who had salt mines and
countries that had salt mines were
really important.
Believe it or not,
countries fought wars over salt.
That changed with refrigeration.
Now we still use salt.
Probably we still use it some to
preserve meat,
but mainly we use it for flavoring and
one thing or another,
unless you are intimately familiar with
Morton's,
you probably don't have any idea where
it comes from.
You don't care.
It's bought and sold on a market.
It's a commodity like a lot of other
commodities,
but nobody is going to order you around
because he's got salt and you don't,
well,
we need to do that oil,
we need to destroy,
not oil,
but we need to destroy it as a strategic
commodity so we don't need it for
transportation.
There are real competitors and the
competitors,
electricity,
alternative fuels together in one.
Some combination,
um,
can get the job done at that point.
Oil becomes like lots of other
commodities and by the way,
it becomes much more operative in a free
market because what you have now is not
a free market.
OPEC runs at a cartel and they are able
run it with Saudi Arabia leading it a
because it's a strategic commodity and
there was no other way for most people
and most structures in the world to
propel their vehicles around except
with,
with the oil,
petroleum derived fuels.
If we can end that.
So there are some competitors that are
close to oils cost like cellulosic
ethanol and others like,
um,
electricity.
There are much cheaper.
People are still gonna want oil.
Depends on how cheap it is.
Whether they use oil or natural gas in
the chemical plant,
etc. Fine.
Don't want to destroy oil.
Want to do to it.
What reFrigeration did assault.